energize your tired hairy face by
shaving with caffeinated shaving cream
just be careful not to Nick your face
transforming hyper lip because it's
episode 56 of loose add some extra
entropy to your existence with the chaos
machine a DIY toy that lets you explore
some of the math and real-world
applications of chaos theory by
connecting a series of pendulums and
axles to a magnet if that repels you
perhaps you'll find a silent guitar more
attractive built to emulate the sounds
of an acoustic guitar simply plug in a
pair of headphones to play discreetly
and quietly wherever you'd like for a
sleek and subtle way to organize scrap
there's the totem intelligent waste
system it takes up as much space as a
typical trash can but is divided into
different compartments so recycling food
waste trash and other household items
can be separated and stored easily ease
your cold sleepy head into the hoodlum a
sleeping bag designed for your dome then
sink your body into an inada Dreamwave
massage chair it offers a full-body
massage with 100 air cells and heated
cushions to help relax and rejuvenate
your entire frame from your feet all the
way to your hand detour the most noble
of all mythological creatures have the
hand atour helps sculpt these blocks of
clay into erasers with the creatable z'
make your own eraser kit sculpt whatever
you want and bake it in the oven to turn
your creation into a functional eraser
raise your organization game and desert
dirty desks with your cork cactus a
prickly pot plant which acts as a pin
cushion and requires no water however
water will be required for the Tarzan
boat a mobile floating water park that
comes with a slide multiple trampolines
a rope ladder and can be parked at a
marina conquer the water and the air
thanks to the parrot hydrofoil drone
which uses four propellers on a mini
drone to charge across the water two
inches above the surface charge up the
luminaid pack light spectra using all
the Sun Lantern has LEDs that change
color the whole thing folds up and
features a durable solar panel on the
top but if you'd rather use the Sun to
draw something you'll need Feb oh the
solar paintbrush made from wood and
glass it can be used to draw with solar
energy by concentrating sunlight on a
specific point now that you've used the
Sun to draw turn out the lights and
watch the sands alive glow an indoor
sandbox that never dries up comes with
different tools to shape the sand and
glows in the dark with your dogecoin
into the sci-fi wallet which not only
looks awesome but when opened makes
sci-fi sounds take your sound untethered
with the air LP wireless streaming
turntable which can connect to bluetooth
speakers making your vinyl collection
cordless and can even connect to your
phone which you can then place inside of
the hog V a vaguely human shaped fill oh
that makes talking with your friends and
family on the phone more of comforting
comfort yourself about potential natural
disasters with a prepper gear box
a monthly box subscription that sends
you gear that'll come in handy should
disaster strike right but does it come
with a hot dog toaster be careful not to
eat too many toasted hot dogs or you'll
end up just like barf and Barney the
desktop gnome honestly Barney it's okay
that you threw up I don't care it all
and as always thanks for watching
you
yeah because it come with a hot dog
toaster yeah but does it come with a hot
dog toaster